vous à nous expliquer entre potes
l'armée que des potes dans que on est
une bande de potes vous nous expliquer
brièvement et simplement ce qu'est le
sionisme le sionisme d'abord c'est le
droit du peuple juif à retourner sur sa
patrie ancestrale est devenu un état qui
est à tora tora tora temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a hélas
opéré
on sait que paraître jeudi
et bien ça y est tu monde est calme et
pour une fois ça vous concerne pas mon
cher klugman
c'était acteurs directs comme quoi tu
vois on s'attend s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît bien donc c'était acteurs on
sait pas très bien pourquoi enfin bon il
ya de la peinture partout et ça
ressemble à du sang ça devient chaud je
faire la terrible et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous y mettez un peu de bleu